25% des yvelinois de plus de 60 ans ne
serait toujours pas vaccinées
c'est le constat annoncé par gabriela
talent en déplacement dans les yvelines
ce jeudi 22 juillet le gouvernement
souhaite un été vaccinale pour limiter
la quatrième vague
nous sommes entrés dans un sprint
vaccinale les rendez vous se sont à
multiplier les prises de rendez vous
depuis l'allocution du président de la
république près de 5 millions de
personnes qui ont pris rendez-vous à la
suite de l'allocution et le pharmacien
que j'ai rencontré ici il me disait
qu'il y avait un véritable engouement de
personnes qui hésitaient à se faire
vacciner et qui à la suite de
l'allocution du président ont décidé de
franchir le pas de se faire vacciner et
la premier ministre a donné un objectif
encore plus important c'est que la
semaine prochaine et la suivante on soit
à 4 millions de premières injections par
semaine 8 millions sur les deux semaines
ce qui est colossal c'est un défi
collectif qui est lancé sept cent mille
doses seront disponibles par semaine
pour les professionnels de santé
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
a annoncé que les préparateurs en
pharmacie pourraient vacciner
une nouvelle saluée par le responsable
de cette officine
on manque de ressources humaines donc
que nous pourrons le faire à la
pharmacie plus nous serons nombreux à le
faire la pharmacie plus nous pourront
vacciner
nous sommes dix donc trois pharmaciens
donc vous voyez du coup si on peut
proposer aux préparateurs de vacciner ça
va ça va nous faire du bien
le vaccin entre dans la stratégie du
pass année terre annoncé par les manuels
macron une mise en place craint par les
professionnels ce restaurant fait 180
couverts par jour le service est assuré
par cette salariée d'un sens de la
gestion ça va nous prendre un petit peu
de temps scanner les gens qui fasse le
job qu'ils arrivaient à vacciner parce
qu'il sera prêt miller des réservations
mais qu'on se retrouve pas avec des tas
pour réserver non vaccinés ça va être
compliqué
mais bon il n'y a pas de raison que ça
fonctionne pas on trouve pas personnel
donc qu'effectivement je vais me
détacher pour le faire mais ça fera une
personne deux mois en salle c'est clair
puisque puisqu'on n'a pas de personnel
pour faire ça donc ça va être un vrai
job à temps complet à mon avis gabriel
attal a rappelé que les contrôles
d'identité seront effectués par les
forces de l'ordre et non par les
responsables des sites concernés
la mesure entrera en vigueur le 1er août
prochain